we see that area is filled with some of
their guests
[Music]
we'll get to some of the descriptions of
why they're there
[Music]
first we want to bring in our panel
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's February 8
2023. it is the day after the State of
the Union
and the state of the union is confused
at best we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe if
you have not if you want to join us for
the post game Wrap Up Show as many of
you have been doing we got a nice little
Community purring over there join us at
reubenreport.locals.com uh yes today we
will be focusing on that uh how long was
the speech about about an hour and a
half last night I do have to be uh
totally honest with you obviously as a
communicator of information uh the first
20 minutes of the thing I have uh some
friends from out of town here we were
smoking some meat eating some potatoes
and vegetables sitting outside we did
have the TV on in the background a lot
of it I had to do just by reading Joe
Biden's lips and with the uh with the
tightness of the face after all the
facelifts and the injections and all the
weird things they do with him I'm not
totally sure that my lip reading was
exactly right but we did go in this
morning to make sure that I got it all
right we're going to play plenty of
Clips we're going to play some of the
reaction and just the whole thing thing
felt so bizarre to me that so many
people and I saw a really strong sense
of this on Twitter that people can watch
the exact same thing and have a
completely different takeaway I do not
sit here every day telling you that I am
right about absolutely everything and we
all have our blind spots and everything
else but I was watching people on
Twitter last night some of whom I
respect some of whom I like some of whom
I've broken bread with watching that
thing thinking and saying the complete
polar opposite
of what my thoughts and reactions were
and that's rather amazing actually one
of the people who was super impressed
with Joe Biden last night and I assure
you I was not we'll get to that
momentarily uh one of the people who was
was my friend and many many time guests
on this show Peter bogosian people
gozian who's a uh you've heard a book
called a manual for creating atheists
he's been a lefty most of his life I'd
say he's he's shifted a little bit maybe
towards my position something like that
over time but we are we are he is
certainly still a lefty in most senses
of it uh we are good buddies and I
happen to be by total coincidence uh I
am interviewing him today later today at
the local Studio here in Miami which is
just absolutely perfect because it is
getting increasingly more difficult to
sit down with people that you disagree
with and I was watching him tweet this
thing and he's talking about Joe Biden
being competent and this is a great
speech and all this stuff and I'm and
I'm literally tweeting out the complete
reverse and I was like all right well
we're are going to sit down and do it
tomorrow and guess what we'll still
break bread after we'll still be friends
after and it'll all be good so I think
that that's just an interesting way to
set the frame for this thing because
this thing where we're all watching the
same movie basically and all this is is
a movie wherein The Show Must Go On
version of democracy at this point we're
watching the show and we're having
wildly different feelings about it and
uh as I often talk about that
bifurcation of America we're all going
in our different directions how long can
that last when we're all you know seeing
the same thing but having very very
different feelings about what basically
is true and real so that is what we are
going to talk about today uh before I
get to it let me talk to you guys about
Birch gold real quick which you might
want to invest in gold after realizing
that that guy has something to do with
the economy despite the U.S blowing
through 31.4 trillion dollar trillion
dollar debt ceiling in January the
leftist White House still refuses to
reduce spending while our national
leadership has buried their heads in the
sand when it comes to fiscal
responsibility it's time to pull yours
out of the sand now would be a great
time to diversify into gold with Birch
gold in times of high uncertainty
uncertainty and instability gold is King
it's Dependable Birch gold makes it easy
to convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals here's what you need to
do visit birchgold.com Dave to claim
your free info kit on gold and then talk
to one of their precious metals
Specialists think about this to dig into
our to dig our country out of this
mountain of debt every single taxpayer
in America would have to write a check
for 247
000 are you guys interested in doing
that sort of thing anyone in the nobody
in this room wants to do that and it's
only getting worse guys protect yourself
today by by visiting birchgold.com Dave
they've got an A-Plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to
protect your future visit birchgold.com
Dave today and now back to me okay so
let's get right into the state of the
union and you know there's a lot of Pomp
and Circumstance and these people the
reason we did that cold open where we
spliced uh Jill walking in with the
Cantina scene on Tatooine in the
original Star Wars is because the more
they show these people in HD and we're
watching them on big screens and
everything they all look kind of broken
and everyone's face is like a little
like this they're pulled like this but
their eyes are like this spiders and
everybody and it's just the type it just
feels like a freaking freak Show anyway
uh before we get to Joe Biden I wanted
to show you one video because we played
a video of her yesterday back to back
days with her we thought we got rid of
this woman Jan sake the former White
House Press Secretary a woman who could
not tell you a single word of truth if
her life depended on it as I often said
if you asked her what her favorite
number was she would say orange uh if
this woman then of course she left the
White House right and what it what
happens when you leave the White House
and you've been fairly horrible at your
job you get a job in corporate press she
now is an analyst a news analyst for
MSNBC do you think she's analyzing the
news properly when we know what all of
her opinions are clearly but she's an
analyst for the news uh anyway yesterday
on MSNBC she gave a little preview of
what Joe Biden was going to do and I
thought this would be an interesting way
to set up the whole show today biggest
speech of the Year any president gives
but what he needs to do is tell a story
Joe Biden is an amazing Storyteller I
mean you sit in the Oval Office screen
can tell you and he can storytell for
six hours
oh Biden is an amazing Storyteller he
can tell a story for six hours you may
remember the story of Corn Pop and the
kids rubbing the hair on his legs and
that's how he learned about roaches and
he loves kids sitting on his lap and he
can do that for six hours shoot me in
the head anyway here's that great
Storyteller telling a story last night
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk that brown and black parents
have had to have with their children Bo
Hunter Ashley my children
I never had to have to talk with him
I never had to tell them if a police
officer pulls you over turn your
interior lights on right away
don't reach for your license
keep your hands on the steering wheel
imagine having to worry like that every
single time
your kid got in a car
ah the story The completely fictitious
story first off I am white as far as I
know unless do you guys know something
that I don't know I am white my dad I
remember when I got my license my dad
sat me down and said actually he sat me
down once and then he said it once when
he was taking me out to drive in the in
the school parking lot he said if you
ever get pulled over you keep your hands
on the steering wheel and gave me a few
other little bites of advice we grew up
in a pretty decent place wasn't much
crime wasn't much problem with policing
but he felt that was an important thing
to say this endless racialization of
everything black and brown kids a lot of
when you mean brown kids do you mean
like Cubans who are brown is this
happening to them do you mean American
Indians who are brownish do you mean
just very tan Italian people from Sicily
who could look a little brown this
obsessive focus on race and you guys
know all the numbers and we've done a
million shows on this whether it was
with Larry Elder or Thomas Soul plenty
of other people that the police are not
out to get unarmed black people and if
you don't fight the police when you are
arrested it is very very very rare that
anything is going to happen to you but
you do have to follow the laws and if
you get pulled over you keep your hands
on the steering wheel
etc etc also that he never had to have
that talk with Hunter Biden
I'm guessing you never had to talk about
smoking crack with Hunter Biden either
because he became a crackhead so it's
not like you're doing such a great job
there either Joe but the storytelling
continued here he got very emotional
because you know when you're telling a
story you have to you can't just be
monotonous you have to inject emotion
into the stories here he is having a
completely disregulated emotion
regarding China
name me a world leader
who changed places with Xi Jinping name
me one
name me one
I don't know what he's talking about I
don't know why he's yelling I checked
with a lot of people I was looking at
seeing people's responses why was he
yelling
who would want to change
uh with jingping uh XI ping I don't know
I don't know why is he yelling about it
but he's disregulated so there are these
moments where in the notes it obviously
tells him to be emotional be stronger
whatever it is and he can't quite
regulate properly he also did not have a
good sort of handle on the audience this
this was very interesting this was one
of the more interesting moments of the
evening he claimed that Republicans
wanted to get rid of Social Security but
watch as he says it he's kind of telling
you that he knows it's not true he has a
little bit of a tell and then a bunch of
Republicans in the audience started
yelling what those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
[Music]
and that may give you anybody who doubts
it contact my office I'll give you a
copy I'll give you a copy of The
Proposal
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see you now I tell you
I enjoy conversion
you know amazing if Congress doesn't
keep the programs the way they are
they'd go away other Republicans say I'm
not saying it's a majority of you I
don't even think it's even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look
folks
the idea is that we're not going to be
we're
so he goes out of his way at first to
imply that it's the Republicans that
want to do this then it's some
Republicans then respectfully it's
somebody but I don't want to name them
anything else there you had I mean you
saw Marjorie Taylor green she's thought
of as sort of like on the really right
right the far right side of the
Republican Party the Trump wing of the
Republican party and there she is
screaming you're a liar that's not what
we want to do Kevin McCarthy is shaking
his head no I don't know any mainstream
Republican that is looking into cutting
Social Security do they talk about how
entitlements are costing us too much
money do they talk about rampant
government spending yes he also of
course links this to if we could just
take more money from rich people and by
the way rich people people making well
certainly over a million dollars but
even people making over a hundred
thousand dollars pay virtually all the
taxes the bottom 50 percent pay
virtually nothing and it's never an
income issue for the government it's a
spending issue right it's that they
spend like drunk in sales dollars it's
like they they spend like crack addicts
trying to get more parmesan cheese out
of the carpet as opposed to saying oh
maybe let's spend a little less so we
have to just take less from other people
but in the Democrat mind in the Biden
mind we just need more money from those
people producing stuff who often the
people producing stuff and making money
they often spend money and hire people
and then those people build businesses
and that's kind of how the whole thing
really is designed to work but if we can
just centralize more of their money and
do what we want with it it would be good
so anyway it was nice to see you know I
keep saying
that Republicans are getting balls right
they're showing some teeth there's a
little bit of a backbone like a ramrod
as some elderly man likes to say uh it
is good that they were pushing back on
that uh and they push back not only on
uh that related to Social Security and
cutting spending uh but Biden and the
Border as it relates to Fentanyl
dogger with you
fentanyl is killing more than 70 000
Americans a year
big
you got it
[Applause]
so let's launch a major surge of stop
fentanyl production
okay first off when I talk about Biden
being disregulated here's the guy that
yelling about China and it doesn't even
make sense why he's yelling and then he
goes into these moments and I think this
has something to do my guess would be I
don't know for a fact but it has
something to do with the medications and
it and it sort of like goes in time or
whatever drip they gave him or anything
else so there he's kind of very slow and
everything else but that's a sidebar the
point of this is that they're yelling at
him completely justly if you Joe Biden
and your party is going to say that
Fentanyl and these hardcore drugs being
brought in through the Mexican border
are bad and I think most of us would
agree that fentanyl is bad it is your
job it is one of the few things that
you're supposed to do as president of
the United States you want to do through
the pen through executive orders you
want to do a whole bunch of stuff that
you're not supposed to do right it's not
really the way we're supposed to be
governed Congress is supposed to write
laws you're just supposed to sign them
you're not supposed to be legislating
through executive action you do all
sorts of that and by the way they all do
it Trump did it Obama did it Clinton did
it fit to do George W bush everybody
okay fine but if you are upset about
fentanyl if you are upset about how
drugs are ravaging our big cities if you
are upset about what I saw two weeks ago
in San Francisco which was beyond we
showed you plenty of the videos Beyond
human imagination what has happened to
that City and the thousands of
zombie-like people wandering all over
that City and the the gross destruction
of that City and Portland and Seattle
and La Etc uh you might want to protect
the border so don't pretend you care
about the 70 000 Americans who have died
of this and the plenty of others the
probably hundreds of thousands if not
Millions who are hooked on fentanyl or
will be soon enough when it is one of
your very specific few duties to protect
that border and you're not doing it so
that's how all the stuff gets here now
what was interesting next is that it
wasn't only the Republicans booing Biden
here he is actually saying something
true it's very bizarre but I like to
give credit where credit is due here he
says something true that we still do
need oil and gas but that is not what
the radicals what the crazy progressives
in his own party want him to admit and
they were not thrilled that he said it
we're still going to need oil and gas
for a while but guess what no they do
but there's so much more to do
we got to finish the job
funny because it's not that he's giving
so much to the oil and gas people you
know it's like we just still need it for
a little while I personally think we're
gonna need it for a lot more than a
little while and I don't think you
morons are able to get us onto truly
green energy that isn't going to cause
more poverty and a whole bunch of other
stuff but okay let's put that aside the
Republicans when they hear that they
hear something saying oh we're going to
kind of need oil and gas for a while and
then we're like okay something's saying
that was nice to hear something roughly
saying but then the progressives when
they hear something saying they have to
start yelling so this is going to be the
tension that he is going to have to live
in but now I want to talk about sort of
the media reaction to some of this stuff
because we could play through all the
clips and I have a feeling if you're
watching the show you probably you know
roughly agree with me on on the general
take of the evening and and the nonsense
and the sort of avoidance of anything
related to kovid that really had any
meat to it or any of that kind of stuff
so what I want to talk about is this
this two different world idea how the
media sees things and sees it in a
complete opposite way than what I would
call is the about fairly obvious truth
so here is from the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC racist crazy
person Joy Reed giving her analysis of
Biden's speech
there's a lot of
Variety in the Democratic sort of pilot
political world about Biden's age
he shattered that tonight he's obviously
his experience it's similar to what
Nancy Pelosi is able to do there's
certain things that an experienced
politician can do to your point Lawrence
that an inexperienced politician even a
Kevin McCarthy who's been around a long
time but is obviously not as ready for
prime time as Joe Biden so I think a
better use of my time today would be to
debunk the media nonsense rather than
just debunking the bite and stuff I
think you guys get that but that Joy
read watched that and suddenly felt oh
his age is no longer an issue and he
just crushed I mean all he did was read
that's all you have to do is read he did
slur a bunch of stuff and and got
confused once or twice but relative to
what we have come to expect from Joe
Biden in terms of standing there and not
falling off the stage it was pretty good
and by the way that is one of the great
advantages that Joe Biden has right now
the bar is so low even for the people
who like him so if you're married to or
live with someone or have a friend who
is a Big Joe Biden supporter and they
really are no Big Joe Biden supporters
they're just a bunch of people that kind
of go along with the Borg there's no
like I think Joe Biden has a great
vision for America Joe's our guy those
people do not exist I'm pretty sure Jill
Biden is even one of those people but
for anyone that is sort of roughly a
Democrat something like that it's like
the bar with this guy is so low all they
need from him to view it as a success
which is kind of what Joy Reed is saying
there is just don't have your eye
explode don't fall off the stage don't
be unable to read and walk off the wrong
way and shake hands with an imaginary
person and completely make up a story
and if you can do all that it will be
irrelevant whether anything that you
said there was true or not for Joy Reid
to have the takeaway that this was proof
that the age isn't an issue he should
run again all that stuff it's like well
if you were impartial and how does she
consider herself impartial as MSNBC I
don't know that she can I don't know
which I guess she does because I think
if you ask Joy Reed she would say she's
a journalist I'm not a journalist and I
don't pretend to be a journalist I think
I'm doing probably something closer to
journalism than she is but that's a
separate issue uh that she would watch
that and think okay this guy is good to
go but it's like all right lady you
watched a couple years of trump doing it
now you may disagree with Trump but did
each time you be like okay well Trump
should run again because obviously he's
mentally fit to do it when he clearly
was was far more mentally fit so let's
continue with the media analysis of all
of this one of the things that Biden
repeatedly said
and has been sort of going through the
messaging the the LIE laundering thing
that the system does is that gas prices
are going down so Corrine Jean-Pierre
was cleaning up a little bit after uh
talking about that and we've seen gas
prices go down again because of the the
okay so she says gas prices go down we
could have played you a longer clip
obviously now we this is what they do
this is a perfect example of how they
lie right in front of your eyes gas
prices went down so RNC research uh
tweeted this out the day that Joe Biden
took office gas nationally so this is a
national average was 2.39 as you
remember a couple months ago when we
were really at the height of all of this
craziness it peaked at about five
dollars a gallon now it's at what is
that roughly that's about 3 30 or so
something like that
yeah something like that I can't quite
see from where I'm looking right now but
the point is it is still above look at
the chart look at the chart it is still
above where it started when he took
office so the idea that he's brought gas
down is absolutely a lie it is above
when he came in by the way I don't think
that everything related to prices of
everything are completely the fault of
the President right or they certainly
shouldn't be in a sane world because you
wouldn't have enough power related to
everything so that if he made a decision
gas stations all over the country would
have to do all sorts of different things
that being said uh in at the height of
this issue when gas was five dollars a
gallon it was basically last summer uh
it was significantly cheaper here and
and significantly more expensive in
California because of extra taxes and
regulations and a whole bunch more
anyway that's just like a very clear
example if you're in a conversation
today and someone brings up to you uh
well did you watch the State of the
Union last night wasn't it great because
gas prices are going down and you can
say to them look I I know you're you're
uh sensitive uh you're a leftist facts
are hard to get through to you if you
put your hands up like this a lot they
they generally will not immediately Maul
you and if and but I just want you to
know the gas was actually 239
uh when Biden came in office it's about
a dollar more than that now and it had
peaked it sort of double that so would
you say that that's really bringing gas
down if it's more than when he came in
office and then you'd have to watch
their heads explode and then then they
call you a racist and walk away but you
could try is what I'm saying anyway uh
here's more from Corinne Jean-Pierre
talking about wages and inflation
when you think about the economy what
the president has done is transformed
the way we think about it right we used
to talk about trickle-down economy he
doesn't say that he doesn't believe in
that he believes in building an economy
from the bottom up middle out and that's
what you've seen and I've talked a
little bit about the data the data
points which is wages are up it's just
words it's just words none of it means
anything you know my feelings on this
they don't believe in a bottom-up
economy a bottom-up economy would be
getting out of your way lowering taxes
getting rid of Regulation if that's what
you mean that's what bottom up that's
what most sane people would think is a
bottom-up economy meaning we the
Citizens first and then there are layers
all the way up to the government okay
government should not really be above
you but this is the way that they view
all of this stuff right
um bottom-up economy would be you work
you keep your money you put that money
into the community into your family buy
a house buy a car do what you want to do
that thing we used to call the American
dream they do the reverse of that thing
they want the top down economy we're
going to tax the flying F out of you and
then occasionally every now and again
when you start choking when you really
are hurting we'll give you a little text
break even though it was your money in
the first place so it's just a lie they
just say these things over and over and
on this idea of trickle-down Economics
as a general rule if you cut taxes for
everyone I would be for cutting taxes
for everyone if you want to know more
about my specific theories on taxes
there's a couple pages on it and don't
burn this book but the basic ideas you
could cut taxes on absolutely everybody
including rich people because when you
cut taxes on them everyone starts
spending more money people don't just
sit on the money you can but most people
don't if you know that if you get your
paycheck you person watching this right
now if you looked at your paycheck next
week and your paycheck had I don't know
say 15 20 percent more now you might say
I'm going to save up for that car I'm
going to save up for that TV whatever it
is but eventually you're going to buy
something with it you're going to do
something with it you might immediately
go out and buy your friends dinner and
tip really well or a Litany of other
things so bottom up would be giving you
the power so these people are just
completely reverse
Fox News uh had an interesting piece
yesterday on what's going on here in
terms of people living paycheck to
paycheck and it was actually quite
shocking because apparently it's a whole
bunch of people who are even making over
a hundred grand a year 166 million
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck the majority of people who are
making more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year say that includes them
living paycheck to paycheck retail
spending has been down in several recent
months and inventories up inflation has
outpaced wage growth for 21 months and
gas prices are up again the last five
weeks in a row okay so the the inflation
wage growth thing is the most important
inflation starts Rising that means your
money is worth less and now if you're
not making as much money that disparity
keeps continuing right you're not making
as much and the stuff is costing more
your dollar goes less far and that is
the disparity we have right now this
concept of of 51 of people making over a
hundred grand or going paycheck to
paycheck is super interesting now I
don't know that you can blame that all
on the the bad economic state that the
country seems to be in I actually think
you can blame a lot about probably on
education over the last 20 years people
don't know how to save people don't know
how to oh I have a credit card it has a
7000 dollar limit I only have 50 bucks
in my bank I guess I could still spend
seven thousand dollars I don't think
there's basic financial literacy in this
country ironically or I guess not
ironically this is completely the
reverse of ironic we're teaching
financial literacy here in Florida
because we are the state of Competency
not the state of confounded idiocy which
is pretty much what's happening from the
national government uh and if you want a
little more on the fundamental
difference between red and blue States
we can talk all day long about the crime
rates in the blue cities you guys know
about that we can talk all day long
about the covid lockdowns in the blue
States you know all about that but I
thought this one was interesting this is
from RNC research 13 of the top 15
states with the lowest unemployment
rates are led by Republican Governors
let's just give shout out to the to the
top five four of them are Republican
states that's Utah North Dakota South
Dakota South Dakota here in Florida of
course and then the fifth one Minnesota
so Minnesota is a democrat-run state got
to give it to him and Phoenix made an
interesting point to me as we were going
through this this morning number 12
there Kansas has a Democrat Governor but
has two Republican Senators right so
that's interesting so Kansas is just
sort of an interesting mix in this I
don't know enough about Kansas
specifically uh related to the economic
policies to really comment on that but
the general Point here you guys get when
Republicans come in and again they're
not that great and they'll often fail
you but when they come in you suddenly
have a little more law and order a
little less homelessness a little less
problem with drugs a little more
economic activity and that is generally
good
one more of Corrine Jean-Pierre I'm just
bludgeoning these people today uh her
response on why Americans are not happy
with the Biden economy despite the fact
she keeps telling everyone it's bottom
up and middle out and a whole bunch of
other meaningless dribble the president
is claiming the state of our economy is
strong but 41 of Americans think they
are worse off financially than they were
when President Biden took office the
most negative response to that question
in the history of ABC polling now if the
economy is strong why don't more
Americans feel that way
because it's been a very hard couple of
years
it's been a hard couple of years was
there something that happened
involving the government that might have
made this difficult on people like a
thing that the government chose to do
that maybe like locked people in their
house and forced people to inject
themselves with weird stuff and not let
kids go to school and basically broke
the brains of like 350 million was
there's I'm gonna have to we'll Google
that lost my pen we'll Google that uh
what she doesn't want you to know of
course is that inflation under this
Administration Has Gone Bananas these
are stats know what they give you they
give you platitudes I'm going to give
you stats here is the inflation here
we're going to break it down over the
series of a couple months January of 20.
it was at 2.5 percent January 21 1.5
July of 21 here's where it started to
move 5.4 percent January of 22 so that's
a year ago now it jumped to 7.5 percent
this past summer July of 22 9.1 and
November 6.5 so yes it has ticked down
lightly as you're looking there but much
like that information we showed you the
graph we showed you about gas prices it
is significantly higher than when Joe
Biden came into office this is why I
show you things with numbers and charts
something that is completely the reverse
of what these clowns on MSNBC do when
they do their live laundering they bring
on Administration people to just say
nonsensical things and then they just
repeat them on MSNBC and speaking of
MSNBC here's Andrea Mitchell who is once
a decent journalist at NBC news now
she's mostly on MSNBC that's where they
put the Amateur hour people and here
she's talking about Biden and China and
there's something interesting Happening
Here the way they're going to start
framing things around China and I think
she might have shown us a little bit too
much behind the curtain here take a look
even these House Republicans will not
separate themselves from Ukraine but on
China what Joe Biden did tonight by not
taking on China more aggressively was
politically
politically courageous if you will in
terms of the domestic support because as
you know very well the polling is that
you know 75 percent of America no
downside getting tough on China yeah
there's no they want us a tougher line
and the Republicans are in line with
that and a lot of Democrats are and
there's going to be a resolution next
week and it's going to pass with
Democratic support well okay so this is
super interesting first Chuck Todd
there's no downside of getting tough on
China and what she's saying is that her
own party and Joe Biden's own
constituents want constituents want him
to be tougher on China he did not do
that so he's given uh she's given Joe a
lot of credit on that now we can go back
and forth all day long and I probably
promise you I'm going to do a whole
bunch more shows on China experts with
China experts because I think this is
really important and this might be the
new sort of Cold War situation that
we're potentially entering and we know
that so much to link it to something
earlier so much of the fentanyl that's
coming through our border is starting in
China we know that millions of young
people have tick tock on their phone and
it is a Chinese spy
and We Know It And we allow it so we got
a huge problem with China on top of the
fact that you know we're relying on
China for so much of our drugs and so
much of our infrastructure and
technology and and they steal technology
and patents and a whole bunch more but
it's interesting the way she's framing
this thing because on one hand she's
saying we do have a China problem
everyone's sort of acknowledging there
is a China problem they've kept us
they've kept our eye off the wall
because we focus so much on Ukraine
right we have a far bigger problem with
China in terms of actually what is
important and relevant to Americans
because China is involved in our
infrastructure China is involved in our
supply chain all of those things Ukraine
is not now Ukraine might Loom large
because they're going to probably start
World War III over it but that's sort of
a separate thing in a way than the
immediacy of China really we we owe
China a ton of money China could start
turning those screws on us we want the
cash guys we want the cash and then what
are we going to do well it's a good
thing we have bombs right it's it's the
mafia move I'm always talking about
um but it's interesting because she's
she's saying he deserves a lot of credit
for not going harder on China and it's
like you might be right there maybe
there's a tactical play there but China
did just have a balloon did you guys
hear about the balloon you heard about
this balloon there was a balloon
floating Over America a Chinese spy
balloon and it was floating for days uh
Biden wanted apparently to take it down
some of the military people let it go
for a little while longer we don't know
it was going over sensitive military
sites we don't know what it took
pictures of video of we don't know what
kind of surveillance it did we we
eventually blew it up but why didn't
the United States uh maybe we should
have they love the U.N these people love
the U.N they love these globalist
organizations why don't we have an
emergency meeting hey China you're not
allowed to float balloons over our
country uh so it is very unclear what
our China policy is my personal belief
that's I don't want to go to war with
China although didn't Joe Biden once say
that uh if China moves on Taiwan that he
would send troops or something I mean
it's it's sort of all over the place
um but okay he he backed off China a
little bit and she's trying to frame
that as something positive maybe it is
maybe it isn't I don't know uh but you
know Joe Biden has been ballooning he's
been blowing hot up he's been blowing
hot air up China's butt for a long time
videotape China is not our enemy I
believe that and I'm even more convinced
now that a rising China is an incredibly
positive development for not only China
but the United States and the rest of
the world it is in our self-interest
that China continue to prosper China is
a great nation and we
arising
China is going to eat our lunch come on
man they're not bad folks folks but
guess what
they're not they're not their
competition for us China's not our
problem we've been helping with some of
their problems
bizarre and so what are we what are we
worried about we talk about China
as our competitor
we should be helping well you think in
retrospect that you were naive about
China no
yes you were or you were just blatantly
negligent China is the number one
geopolitical foe it is it is their
sphere of influence that is spreading
throughout the world it is the ideas of
the Communist Party of China on top of
the fact that it is very likely that
covet itself emanated from Wuhan China
that does not make you racist to say did
fauci fund it too over there yeah okay
fine so we're maybe in on it together
but why for years and years and years
has Joe Biden been kind of going out of
his way to make it seem like China is
not a problem it's not a threat we would
just like a stronger China
etc etc and now we know and Joe even
freaking Andrea Mitchell is admitting it
and Chuck Todd that both parties are
kind of even in agreement that China is
bad news now
there's something going on there I
haven't formulated the whole thing on
this one but as I said we'll get some
China experts on and we'll continue to
talk about this uh I'm sorry to say I'm
about to show you a video of ilhan Omar
so if this is your time to go to the
bathroom you probably should here we go
so you know the president has always
been understood as someone who can unite
a divided country that's one of the
reasons people voted for him
um you know instead of voting for Trump
I think it's really important for there
to be few people that we identify that
we can work with in a bipartisan matter
isn't this interesting
um we'll get to the divided country part
but Joe Biden can fix that we'll get to
that in a second uh she talks about how
she wants to work in a bipartisan manner
with people she's a Democrat but she's
because this woman is evil she's
actually saying something very profound
there she knows she's not really in the
same party as Joe Biden she is a whacked
out Socialist Communist Progressive
racist blah blah blah
but in Her Mind by working with Joe
Biden she's doing something that is
bipartisan right and she's playing along
for now right and and trust me when they
when they come to fully hollow out the
Democrat Party she will be one of the
front front leaders on that thing that's
why there are no moderates left in the
Democrat Party people like her basically
have taken over Biden is kind of hanging
on by a thread to keep a little of that
like true abject Insanity out of the
party but that's kind of where we're at
but she wants to work with bipartisan
people that's why she likes Joe Biden
except she's that's not bipartisanship
bipartisanship would be working with the
Republicans that would be working with
the other people not the people in your
party that you're just more radical than
okay fine but she thinks that Joe Biden
is a uniter and I was like well wait a
minute we must if Elon Omar said it for
God's sakes it must be true find me a
video of the man being a uniter because
he's a uniter uniter Unite
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic he'll
unite all of you people to freaking take
out those deranged Mega Republicans
those 75 million people who just voted a
different way yeah that's the uniter
just absolutely ridiculous uh Nancy
Pelosi who is no longer uh in charge on
the Congressional side she's no longer
doing the sitting back there chewing on
her Dentures during these speeches she
went on is this from MSNBC I think too
this is CNN she went on CNN and praised
Biden for talking about fentanyl a word
that she struggled with
he talked about
the issues that relate to fence
fentanyl yeah fentanyl but also mental
health issues that sort of relate to
that everyone screws up words I screw up
words sometimes fine there's something
about her hands can we just can we we
can't put that in the corner here can we
can't do that right now something about
the way oh we're going to show another
one of her in a second like when she's
talking about mental health people that
talk to you and they're kind like what's
going on here lady are you just cracked
out of your mind like what what's
happening here but if she is upset about
fentanyl which again Joe Biden talked
about fentanyl earlier and they booed
him for what she should really care
about is the Border if you really care
about Fender you should really care
about where it's coming from and all
you'd have to do is choke it off and
then eventually there would be no people
on fentanyl really it's basically as
simple as that here's some border
crossing data uh since uh Joe Biden has
taken over and here's what's going on
here January of 20 we have 36 000
illegals cross January of 21 78 000 in
January of 22 154
000 and December of 22 because I don't
think we have the January numbers full
yet 251
000 people we have no idea where these
people are we send them all across the
country uh they could be bringing in
fentanyl they could be bringing in more
dangerous drugs than that because
there's always a more dangerous drug out
there they could be spiking other drugs
they could be committing all sorts of
crimes but she pretends she cares about
the food
and she doesn't want to do jack
actually about it but here she is I'm
pretty sure she smoked a little do you
smoke fentanyl are you are you why do I
always look at you when these things
happen for some reason I don't know why
that is my default position does anyone
know do you smoke fentanyl or Daphne do
you smoke fentanyl or snort it all right
the point is I'm pretty sure Nancy
Pelosi's on fentanyl because listen to
this
Joe Biden is a person of gut Vision
knowledge judgment
strategic thinking to get the job done
he was a remarkable two years a
remarkable two years and again connects
very empathetically with the American
people so I hope he runs I'm formed if
he runs and I know that the Democrats
will fully Embrace him if he runs it's
over you remember that scene and When
Harry Met Sally when uh what's her name
Meg Griffin Meg Griffin is that the girl
When Harry Met Sally he was Billy
Crystal and Meg Ryan Meg Ryan they're
sitting at uh I think it's cantor's Deli
in New York City and she fakes the
orgasm and she's faking the orgasm
everyone's looking at her then the old
lady looks at her is a very famous line
like back in like 88 89 something like
that I'll have what she's having I kind
of want whatever Nancy Pelosi's on to
see the world in such a bang-up opposite
way all the time and get out there and
sell that Vision you gotta kind of
admire it and distinguish he's a man of
vision and he can see things and he's
great he's worked
oh God
just just give me enough strength people
to keep going
um he's a man of vision though that was
the point he's a man of vision he's a
man who knows what he's saying he's a
man who's doing the right thing he's a
man who cares he doesn't want to scare
people he's a uniter and to prove that
we found this video
and that's happening in Europe but it's
here now and it's spreading and it's
going to increase
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospital they'll soon overwhelm
but there's good news if you're
vaccinated you have your booster shot
you're protected from severe illness and
death
literally not a word that that mask
said was true but he's a man of
good judgment he's a man of great vision
he's the greatest man who's ever lived
he just can't seem to get anything right
so tonight
I'm announcing that the Department of
Labor is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers with 100 or
more employees that together employ over
80 million workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week the vaccine requirements in my plan
will affect about 100 million Americans
just remember he tried to scare the hell
out of everybody by forcing people and
coercing people right because that was
the whole idea if we if we can push
these mandates on companies with over a
hundred people then they're going to all
do it so he pushed people into taking
what Dr Robert Malone who I have on the
show this week part one is up already
who owns more patents on mRNA technology
than anyone what he has described as I
want to get the quote basically roughly
right he says that the vaccine injuries
are going to be far worse than what we
know right now you can see that video
the full things up on locals and clip
two will be up later today on Rumble and
YouTube
um so he did that he tried to scare the
hell out of you about the hospitals that
you'll overwhelm there was no apology
imagine it see there there are ways for
even people that I disagree with
politically so let's say I disagree with
virtually everything that comes out of
Joe Biden's mouth at this point and I do
pretty much it would be almost
impossible for Joe Biden to say
something that I would think was
sensible and honest in anything else but
there are ways that he could actually
Bridge the divide a little bit imagine
if he would have started that speech
last night as this great thinker and
uniter and wonderful man that Nancy
Pelosi says he is imagine if he would
have started that speech last night and
said hey guys
I gotta have a bit of a Maya culpa here
you know we're sort of three years off
this covid thing and we all made
mistakes everybody made mistakes some of
my mistakes included repeating things
like if you get vaccinated you will not
get nor transmit covid some of my
mistakes included using the power of the
federal government to force people to do
medical procedures that they did not
want done and we forced too many people
out of jobs and now we're seeing some of
the repercussions of that imagine if he
had just opened with that we could have
actually had some level of a healing
moment right it is not impossible but it
is impossible for these people because
the media just keeps laundering the lies
and makes you forget everything that
they've done so then he lies about all
of this stuff he creates all of this
chaos related to covid and vaccines and
lockdowns and destroys the economy and
they lie about gas prices when he got in
and where they are now or inflation when
he got in and where it is now and then
the media just moves on and then people
literally and again I think they are
they are not well in the head someone
like Joey Reed she then watches that
speech and says that guy should run
again
he is drugged do you guys not realize
that they are drugging and dripping him
with something it's going to come out at
some point you would not want that man
babysitting your grandchildren not just
because of the sniffing hair he's going
to leave the stove on the stove I guess
he's going to shut down the stove the
electric stove can stay on it's not
that's not going to do anything anyway
how about a little sanity now for a
moment so the Republican response was
done by new Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and I thought it was
quite good now I get it I I I happen to
agree with her on a lot of the issues
but I thought the calmness and Clarity
that she spoke with really really was
excellent and it's a damn shame you know
in the old days in the old days kids
they used to give you the Republican or
Democrat response virtually right after
the thing so the president would speak
he would pretty much walk through you
know shake some hand smile five minutes
later the response for some reason last
night the response was delayed a bit
longer so most people tune out but here
is Sarah Huckabee Sanders giving the
Republican response and I think I think
this line in particular this portion of
it she really kind of nailed what's
going on here
whether Joe Biden believes this madness
or is simply too weak to resist it his
administration has been completely
hijacked by the radical left
the dividing line in America is no
longer between right or left
the choice
is between normal
or crazy
yeah that pretty much is it it's not
right or left in a traditional way it's
not democrat or republican in a
traditional way it's do you see reality
or not and a certain amount of people do
not see reality and they are pushing
that that distorted worldview on
everyone else
here's Joe Biden last night
completely disregulated when it comes to
something that I think we all know is
biologically true taken away in Roe v
Wade and protect Roe v Wade
[Music]
the vice president and I are doing
everything
exact access to reproductive Health Care
in Safeguard patient safety but already
more than a dozen states are enforcing
extreme abortion bans make no mistake
about it if Congress passes a national
ban I will veto it
but let's
all follow the Act Venture LPG lgbtq
Americans especially transgender young
people can live with safety and dignity
our strength
it's such pandering nonsense let's just
put the abortion thing aside for a
moment except for one comment which I
want to make which is that the way they
use language that abortion is somehow
reproductive health care if you are
having an abortion you're not
reproducing and it ain't the health care
of the baby fairly certain on that I
just want this doesn't matter whether
you're pro-abortion or against abortion
let's just be clear and honest with the
language but they're really really good
at this and that's why they get so many
non-thinking people to go along with
them are you for Reproductive Health
Care well I like reproduction and I like
healthcare I must be for Reproductive
Health Care you know that involves
killing a baby what are you a racist you
guys get it what's the other one they
always do when you chop off a child's
genitals what do they call it gender
affirming it is not affirming if you cut
off a girl's boobs
nor a boy's penis okay I want to be fair
to everybody here that's not affirming
that would be very unaffirming but
they're very very good on that sort of
thing and then this idiotic thing the
equality act or whatever it's like there
are no laws stopping gay people from
doing anything in America okay people
you can't get on boats or whatever
lesbians you're not allowed to cut down
trees I always lesbians I always put
them in a forest you know there
um it's all silly nonsense but it
becomes dangerous when it is that they
want to put laws in place that are
literally going to mutilate children
right that's what they're going to do so
I thought we could end the show today by
showing you some normalcy what would be
uh normal and as Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said right it's like sort of crazy
versus normal what would be what would a
speech by a president that was proud of
America that was instituting policies
that made sense that was helping the
economic engine go that was talking
about the Border honestly that wanted to
make sure if you commit a crime you
would be punished for it etc etc well we
don't have to go back that far to find
one how about about three years ago
here's a guy named Donald Trump giving
his State of the Union Address in 2020
and just tell me if you think the tone
of this thing and the content is a bit
different
and my fellow citizens three years ago
we launched the Great American comeback
tonight I stand before you to share the
incredible results
are booming incomes are soaring
poverty is plummeting
crime is falling confidence is surging
and our country is thriving
and highly respected again
[Applause]
obviously didn't applaud on that that's
also the speech you may remember Pelosi
at the end right because they they
really respect things so I saw all these
uh you know MSNBC all those people were
screaming yesterday oh it's so rude that
they call Joe Biden a liar and it's like
do you remember Pelosi do you remember
that Pelosi as she was trying to make
sure her Dentures didn't fall out of her
mouth but the other part of that
uh is that what Donald Trump said was
true there was a newfound respect not a
new founder there was a resurgent
respect for America that was happening
during those four years there was peace
in the Middle East more peace deals
signed in the Middle East right there
were good things happening economically
and even culturally and low black
unemployment and all of those things but
that's not what the business of what
these people are into right they're just
not into that uh here's a little bit
more from Donald Trump that same speech
this is the place where the pilgrims
landed at Plymouth
and where Texas Patriots made their last
stand at the Alamo
the beautiful beautiful Alamo The
American Nation was carved out of the
vast Frontier by the toughest strongest
fiercest and most determined men and
women ever to walk on the face of the
Earth
our ancestors Brave the unknown
tame the Wilderness settled the wild
west lifted Millions from poverty
disease and hunger
vanquished tyranny and fascism ushered
the world to new heights of science and
medicine
laid down the railroads
dug out the canals raised up the
skyscrapers and ladies and gentlemen our
ancestors built the most exceptional
Republic ever to exist in all of human
history and we are making it greater
than ever before
isn't that wild looking back on that
like he's telling you all these great
things not about what's happening just
happening in America today but going
back to the history acknowledging the
people that live before us that built
this absolutely freaking remarkable
Republic that has freed people the world
over and when he says it
we're not into that we're not into that
because you're orange and your hair is
weird man and we're not into that
things were a lot better than things
were a lot better so how do we wrap this
show up properly because uh to show you
that Trump was doing it right and we all
know it and to show you that Biden's
doing it wrong and we all know it that's
not quite right and then I was I
mentioned at the top of the show I've
got my uh my buddy here from out of town
with his uh his girlfriend
we've been friends for 40 we met
literally the first day at kindergarten
so we've been friends now for about 41
years I think we were five years old
first day of kindergarten maybe four and
a half whatever it is then we've been
doing this for a long time and we
watched that thing last night and we had
a little tequila we're sitting in the
hot tub we're talking about politics
talking about everything he actually
evolved on a lot of this stuff before me
he's one of the people that actually
helped me wake up to some of this stuff
he was a trump supporter before I was
okay fine but what we were talking about
was this this thing that I'm always
focusing on this we're all watching the
same thing
and we're seeing two different movies
and what do we do about that and what we
both sort of agreed on at the end is
that it may be possible
uh this is somewhat black pill
depressing it may be possible that at
the federal government level this thing
cannot be fixed that the swamp is so
swampy that the Machinery of DC is so
corroded and corrupted that it cannot be
fixed but it still can be fixed at the
state level it still can be fixed at the
local level and I do think if you do
enough of that that then we could then
export that to even fix the federal
level that's the white pill version of
it right uh and how do you do that well
you just have to look I happen to live
in the place that you have to look at
yeah that Florida place I think I only
said Florida once during this show uh
here is Rhonda santis governor of
Florida
underscoring that Florida blueprint that
I think can fix this thing
and I think some of the things that we
do that work are uh we're all about
exercising leadership and delivering
results for the people that we represent
I did not take any polls when I became
Governor all the way through this entire
term the job of a leader is not to stick
your finger in the wind and try to
contort yourself to wherever a public
opinion may be trending on one given
moment no the job of a leader is to set
out a vision to execute that Vision to
show people that it's the right vision
and to deliver concrete results and when
you do that the people respond and boy
on November 8th did they ever respond in
the state of Florida
and that's it guys that's it you get a
leader who leads who's proud of the
country so look I know there's a little
tension right now between the Trump camp
and the DeSantis Camp DeSantis again has
not announced that he is running for
president I do not know if he is running
for president Trump's been kind of going
at him on Truth social uh and and if
DeSantis gets involved obviously it's
going to get somewhat bloody and the
media will freaking love it and and I
really do believe this the media
actually will be pro-trump in that fight
because they think DeSantis is the real
threat which in my opinion he actually
is because of the the Machinery that he
has built and the success he has built
in Florida uh but all of that being said
I just showed you two pretty freaking
spectacular Trump videos two right so he
did a great job too there is messaging
and policy here that does make sense
that can get us in a better position
than we are in right now and that
reminds me of this picture you may
remember this this is right after
Hurricane Ian when Biden came down to
South Florida subsequently Biden and
FEMA cut their made to Florida but there
was Ron DeSantis standing right in front
of the president of the United States
official seal and yeah the the future
could be bright I think I think it can
be bright I think it will be bright but
we got some work to do and ultimately
it's not us and that's the beauty of
this Republic that we live in but it's
only a republic as long as we can keep
it ladies and gentlemen we've got a post
game show coming up in just mere moments
at
reubenreport.locals.com as I mentioned
part one of my interview with Dr Robert
Malone is up right now the full thing is
up ad free over at locals we're going to
cold close you with Joe Biden in case we
didn't hit you over the head with enough
Joe Biden and I will be back
momentarily
I spend more time working on these cars
than with my own family
I spend my days digging holes cutting
grass and sweating this is job number
two today so my customers aren't the
only ones drinking coffee I'm breaking
my back out here for one reason I want
to pay off some other guy's debt Biden's
plan to pay other people's college loans
using my tax dollars is a great idea
Biden's right you should take my tax
dollars to pay off your debts my family
will figure out how to get by with less
what's most important is we spare
college graduates from any extra stress
want to be a struggling artist
college is on me my kids don't need
fancy things like school supplies or new
shoes I work for you theater major this
shift is for you business major go buy
yourself that new car
enjoy your Free Ride college is on me
tell Congress stop Biden's bailout for
rich kids
[Music]